JULIA FERRAIOLI:
Hey, everybody.
Welcome to this session on
distributed databases.
This panel is really designed
to give you an overview of
some various approaches, some
best practices, and give you
the opportunity to ask questions
to these industry
experts that we've gathered
here on stage today.
So let's get started.
My name is Julia Ferraioli, and
I am a developer advocate
working on Google
Compute Engine.
BRIAN DORSEY: And I
am Brian Dorsey.
And I'm a developer programs
engineer working on Compute
Engine and cloud storage.
And we will be your
hosts today.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Excellent.
But why should you care about
distributed databases?
BRIAN DORSEY: We think this is
an incredibly exciting time in
the world of databases
in general.
And the NoSQL world in
particular has been exploring
a wide variety of ways to
distribute your data.
And the different databases
have very individual
approaches to how they approach
high availability,
reliability, and scalability.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: And with vast
computing resources available
to us on demand, we're able to
gather more and more data,
turning it into actionable
information.
This information is
how we grow, how
we develop and improve.
It's far too important to
be lost to a crash.
BRIAN DORSEY: Or some kind
of natural disaster.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Or a klutz
tripping over the wrong cable.
BRIAN DORSEY: And as an
industry, we've usually dealt
with this sort of thing by
implementing failover or some
kind of backups.
And we really believe that the
way forward is to distribute
your data onto a large
number of machines.
And you're going to want a
database that's designed for
that world.
You want a database that, as you
add more machines, you get
more reliability.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So the last
reason is actually rather
self-serving.
We all like to relax
once in a while.
So with a well-chosen,
well-configured database
solution, you can ditch that
dreaded on call pager and
finally get a good
night's sleep.
So let's introduce
our panelists.
First off, we're going to hear
from Tyler Hannan from Basho,
then Mike Miller, representing
Cloudant.
BRIAN DORSEY: Then we'll have
Chris Ramsdale from the Google
Cloud Datastore and Will
Shulman from MongoLab.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: OK,
Tyler, you are up.
TYLER HANNAN: Beauty.
Thank you, Julia and Brian.
So as they said, my name is
Tyler Hannan, and I'm with
Basho Technologies.
A little bit about Basho--
we were founded in
January of 2008.
There's about 140 of us now.
We have offices sort of strewn
about the world.
But as a company building
distributed systems, we're
kind of neurotic about the term
distributed, and we're a
distributed team as well.
So about 80% of us
work from home.
So when thinking our product,
Riak, our database, it's good
to start by considering
the benefits of
a distributed database.
We believe that Riak is a very
operationally friendly
database that is
fault-tolerant.
It can survive a node failure.
It's highly available.
It can survive network
partition events.
It's scalable.
You can grow to meet demand
simply by adding hardware or
compute instance, and
it's self-healing.
Self-healing is an interesting
one, because in any of the
events above, be they good,
bad, or indifferent,
your data is safe.
So if those are the benefits,
what are the properties of
Riak that those benefits
are derived from?
Riak is a key/value
value store.
It's open source.
It's distributed.
It's masterless.
It's eventually consistent.
Each of these could be a talk
in their own right.
So I'm just going to touch on
a few very, very briefly.
Riak is a key/value store, which
means you have very,
very simple operations--
gets, puts, deletes.
And the value is
mostly opaque.
It's stored on disk as binary.
I append a key to that
value, either
programmatically or manually.
And those key value pairs are
stored in a higher level name
space called a bucket.
I interact with these key value
pairs via either an HTTP
or protocol buffers API.
And there's a slew of client
libraries for it, some of
which we've built, some which
others have built.
Pick a language, there's
a library.
And then we've layered some
extras on top of that-- some
lightweight JavaScript and
Erlang MapReduce, full text
search, secondary indices, pre-
and post-commit hooks.
Importantly, though,
Riak is masterless.
If you're new to the world of
distributed systems and
distributed databases in
general, I encourage you to
read the Dynamo specification.
It's a white paper
that's seminal
to describe an approach.
And it's the approach that
Riak has adopted.
A masterless deployment means
that any node can serve any
request, that data and load
are spread evenly.
This is achieved through
a combination of gossip
protocol, which is mesh
network-like, hinted hand off.
But the point is that you can
achieve near linear scale by
simply adding hardware
or compute instance.
And what does that look like?
It's really three commands--
riak-admin cluster join,
cluster plan-- here's what's
going to happen to your datas
and the replica thereof, and
cluster commit, and you're off
and running.
In the context of what we're
talking about with Google,
that's as simple as firing up
gcutil or the Python APIs,
giving it a project, choosing
a machine type--
n1-standard-4, because we all
like memory as databases--
SSHing in and setting it up,
and you're off and running.
So when would Risk make
sense for you?
If you want an operationally
friendly database, and you
want to combine that with an
operationally scalable compute
platform like Google Compute.
And you're in gaming, social,
mobile, retail,
advertising, whatever.
Forget about the term
"big data." Think
about critical data.
When your data is critical, when
it must be served with
high availability and low
latency, then you want to look
into a distributed system.
And Riak may be a good one.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE MILLER: Can everybody
hear me OK in the back?
Well, my name's Mike Miller.
I'm one of the co-founders
from Cloudant.
And I'm going to give you
three quick slides, just
pictures actually.
And while I'm a technical
founder, I'm going to try to
keep this high level
and get to the
question and answer session.
So how many of you are mobile
developers or have that is a
big part of your work?
How many of you have databases
that are so big that you can't
fit them on a single machine?
Everybody that is writing a
mobile app, if you app is
successful, you'll eventually
hit that point.
And so really, that's one of the
two main reasons that we
founded Cloudant.
So my background is in big
scale systems from Large
Hadron Collider.
And when we were trying to
build that and serve a
globally distributed populace
on 200 datacenters, we
realized that two things broke
our model of computing.
One was big data, and the
other was the fact that
everybody was in a
different place.
That last one has been
rebranded as mobile.
And the fact that scale is
important and masterless and
distributed and all the things
we're going to talk about, you
should just take for granted.
I'm not going to go
in those details.
You should have a service that,
when it needs to grow,
you put nodes in it.
And that service
gets bigger and
faster in a linear fashion.
That's all great.
But the other thing is to attack
the latency problem.
What we realized when we're
solving that at the LHC was
really that what we wanted was
to take a database and take a
content distribution network,
like Akamai, and merge them
together so that I could
have my device, and
I could write locally.
And then it would synchronize
when it could in the lowest
latency fashion possible.
So you've got 200 precious
milliseconds for every user
interaction.
And that means that if you're
going around the globe, you
spend 50 milliseconds getting
off your phone.
So with Cloudant, we've
built a distributed
database as a service.
We run it so that you
don't have to.
You can focus on your
core competency.
And we're, I think, rolled out
on something like 18 to 20
datacenters around
the globe now.
So our big thing is footprint
and giving you a low latency
connection wherever you
are so that you write
local and think later.
And so it's one database
that I think a strong
recommendation I have.
As you choose new technologies,
choose something
that has a mobile strategy
baked in.
So we heard what it's like
to install Riak--
awesome.
This is what it's like
to install Cloudant.
You sign up.
You get a
username.cloudant.com-- done.
And then you get access
and resources
automatically around the globe.
So you write local, and your
data is beating you around on
the globe as your users move.
And the way this works
is pretty simple.
You can actually use
this cloud API.
So we speak the Apache
CouchDB API.
Beneath that, we've [INAUDIBLE]
the same concepts
from Amazon's Dynamo
paper around
distribution and quorum.
So that can handle megabytes
to petabytes.
But you can also run a local
instance of an open source
project on your desktop
machine.
Or you could actually
run it in the
browser, store state locally--
so the local store HTML5.
And you can even run this
on iOS and Touch.
And the cool thing there is you
can always write locally
and preserve that full
offline experience.
So in terms of what I think you
should have in your head
as you think about choosing your
database technologies,
think about what things you're
forced to do with your
database that you'd
love to get away.
And so we're trying to give you
a chance to say hey, do I
really need global
write master?
Or can I just put data someplace
locally and have
that distribution happen
automatically?
So with that, I'll
pass on the mic.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Thanks, Mike,
and thanks, Julia and Brian.
I'm Chris Ramsdale.
I'm a product manager for the
Google Cloud Platform.
And I'm focused on App Engine
and distributed storage within
the platform itself.
The Cloud Platform storage
family is comprised of Google
Cloud Storage for serving blob
data, Cloud SQL for relational
data, and the newly released
Cloud Datastore for
non-relational data.
And for the sake of today, we're
going to focus on the
Cloud Datastore.
And I've got a few slides, and
we'll get going, and then
we'll drop it into
Q&A as well.
So announced yesterday, the
Google Cloud Datastore was our
efforts to extract out the
higher application datastore
that was part of App Engine and
make it available to any
compute container, be it
EC2 or Compute Engine
or things like that.
Launched in 2011, the high
replication datastore turned
out to be a really great project
and a really good
service for our users.
We've gone for two years.
We're at about 4.5 trillion
transactions per month right
now storing petabytes of data.
Jokingly, App Engine has really
been referred to as the
SDK for BigTable.
So what we did was we said,
that's great, but it's
packaged up in the App Engine
SDK, so you can't get to it
from anywhere else.
And so we pulled that out.
We put an HTTP interface
on top of it.
I'm not really doing justice
for what we did to the API,
but you should go
read the docs.
And now we're announcing it as
the Google Cloud Datastore
and, again, making it available
from anywhere.
And by doing that, not only
do we get the hardened
productivity or the
productization of HRD and now
inside of Cloud Datastore, we
also get the features and
functionality, for example,
asset transactions, eventual
strong consistency, a built-in
query engine that lets you do
fixed cost queries and
things like that.
Those are all available
as well.
So that's what the product is.
And real quickly, we're going to
talk about how that aligns
with what our philosophies are
and what we're trying to do
within the Google Cloud
Platform all up.
So at it's core, we're trying to
bring Google infrastructure
to developers, to our customers,
to you that are in
this room today and joining us
for Google I/O. Specifically,
the same infrastructure that's
running things like Geo and
Mail and Google Maps and Search
and things like that.
And what that is specifically
in the case of storage, is
these components that you see
here on the left hand side
that Urs had talked about
yesterday in the Cloud keynote
if you happened to see it--
everything from our datacenters
and our machines
to our networking to the crazy
services that we've built over
the past few years--
Colossus, BigTable,
and Megastore.
And by doing that, what we allow
you to do is we bring
you high availability.
By building on top of Megastore,
we actually give
you the replication across
multiple geos.
We give you high scalability.
So Colossus for actually giving
you the stores, the
underlying mechanism
for storing.
It gives you a huge capacity and
high durability, and then
BigTable for horizontal
scaling out.
So we do that automatically
for you.
You don't have to actually add a
node to the Cloud Datastore.
We just shard appropriately
and things happen.
And finally, an API frontend
that's actually built on top
of App Engine that we'll
just scale out.
We're looking for access
from anywhere.
We think that data it should
not be siloed.
It should follow you
wherever you go.
And as our platform expands
out and as customers use
hybrid approaches like Compute
Engine in EC2, they want their
data to follow them wherever
they need to go.
And then finally, what's
near and dear to my
heart is Fully Managed.
I think that we're all going to
talk about management and
how we do it as we get into the
Q&A. And what that means
for us at Google is that
you get this guy.
This is Michael Handler.
He's one of our Site Reliability
Engineers.
We call them SREs.
And they help keep the service
up and running.
They help us do planning,
architecture, failovers,
things like that.
But because you're building on
the same infrastructure as all
those other products I alluded
to, you not only get him.
You get him cloned
like 1,000 times.
So you've got all these teams
that are monitoring all these
services that do automatically
scale out for you.
But sometimes things happen.
And we've got the cell phone,
AKA the pager to take care of
it and make sure you don't have
to worry about it so you
get more sleep.
I'll turn it over to WIll.
[APPLAUSE]
WILL SHULMAN: Hello everyone.
My name is Will Shulman.
I'm the CEO and co-founder
of MongoLab.
I'm going to give you an
introduction to MongoDB and
our MongoLab Lab
cloud service.
It's upside down.
So real quick, what
is MongoDB?
MongoDB is an open source,
high-performance, distributed,
and document-oriented
database.
And I'll go through what that
means really quickly.
First and foremost, MongoDB
is a document database.
It doesn't mean, for those of
you who are not familiar with
that terminology, it doesn't
mean it stores PDF files.
It means it stores these
rich JSON documents.
MongoDB stores these in a binary
representation of JSON
called BSON.
And this is a really important
part of MongoDB that really
differentiates it from other
NoSQL databases.
It's not just a key
value store.
It gives you these rich
data structures.
It's got nested objects.
It's got arrays.
You can represent geolocations
natively.
And also, unlike a lot of
key/value stores, MongoDB has
a rich query language.
It's a real database.
It allows you to do searching
and sorting by not just the
keys, but any nested value.
So here we have all sorts of
examples of doing queries and
geolocation, if you
look down at this
example towards the bottom.
It's built in.
It's got aggregation, so you
can do binning and grouping
like you would with a
relational database.
And also like a relational
database, although you can
search and sort by anything,
you can create indexes on
almost anything.
So if your queries are slow,
you can index on any field
value, nested key values
deep inside the object.
You can index on array values.
Makes it really great, not just
for a large data sets,
which I'll talk about in a
minute, but really as a
replacement for MySQL or any
relational database you use.
If you spent an inordinate
amount of time in your life
mapping from your
object-oriented programming
language to a relational
datastore and doing
object-relational mapping, you
don't have to do that anymore.
Second, MongoDB is a distributed
database.
There are two clustering
technologies with MongoDB.
The first clustering
technology is
called Replica Sets.
This is what allows
you to have high
availability in MongoDB.
It's single master.
So you can read and write.
It supports both strong
consistency and eventual
consistency.
So if you need strong
consistency for your
application, you can have it.
If eventual consistency
is acceptable for your
application, you can also read
from these secondaries.
And its consistency model is
very, very configurable.
The second clustering
technology is
called Shard Clusters.
This is basically a cluster
of clusters.
So it's a cluster
of Replica Sets.
And with Sharding Clusters, this
is how you get horizontal
scalability with MongoDB.
Like many have mentioned, as you
add nodes to the system,
your rights get distributed
amongst them, and it just
scales linearly in a very
horizontal manner.
What is MongoLab?
So MongoLab is MongoDB
as a service.
And that's what we do.
MongoLab really is about
automating all of the
operational aspects of
our running database.
We try to build an expert system
out of the DBA so that
you don't have the DBA.
You don't have to have
the ops guys.
And you can focus, like a lot
of folks have mentioned, on
building your app.
We handle provisioning
and scaling,
replication and backups.
We've got rich Web UI.
We handle all the monitoring,
all the alerting.
And of course, all with the
service comes expert support.
Our product offering offers
shared and dedicated VM plans.
We have SSD backed plans, single
and multi-node plans.
So whether you're doing
analytics and you just need a
single node database, or you
need lots of nodes, we're
going to have full sharding
support in 2014.
And we run on all sorts of cloud
providers, and we're
here today and this week to
announce our support for the
Google Cloud Platform,
which we're really,
really excited about.
So thank you very much.
We've got a sandbox.
I guess I lost my last slide.
I just wanted to say we've got
a sandbox outside tomorrow at
Google I/O, where you can come
and get a demo of our service.
So we encourage you
guys to stop by.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Thanks, guys.
That was a great overview.
And this is the fun part
where we jump into
some Q&A by the audience.
I encourage you if you have
questions, start lining up at
the mics now.
To jump start it, we'll
just seed a question.
We're at Google I/O.
Most of us were
at Urs's talk yesterday.
So we heard a lot about the
improvements and the type of
infrastructure that
we have at Google.
So my first question, and this
can be answered by everybody,
is, what makes Google's
infrastructure a great place
to run distributed databases?
We'll start with Will.
WILL SHULMAN: So we've actually
been using GCE for a
little while.
And first thing actually
is the network.
The network is a, it's blazing
fast, really, really
impressive.
The other thing that's great
about the Google Cloud
Platform is it has a private
distributed backbone between
all the datacenters.
So we're really excited about
that functionality.
We're really excited to offer
globally multi-region clusters
where you can have nodes--
different parts of the globe.
But you're not talking over
the open internet.
You're actually talking over
Google's private backbone.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: So it's slightly
different for us,
because we're not actually
building on top of Compute
Engine VMs, at least today.
But I think there's an analogy
that I'll get to real quickly,
which is that for the same
reasons that it's good to
build on Compute Engine for all
the services they provide
and the fast networking and the
things that Google takes
care of, it's the same reason
we chose to build on top of
things like Megastore and
Colossus and BigTable and
whatnot and are looking at
things like Spanner as well,
because those are the lower
level pieces that are handled
by Google, much like the lower
level VMs are inside of
infrastructure.
And then also at the same time,
while you can access the
Cloud Datastore from
things like EC2 or
Rackspace or whatnot--
although I think the
latency might be
a little bit awkward--
we really built this for Compute
Engine users, because
we do think it's one of the
great platforms that we're
offering and bringing into the
larger cloud platform.
And so we wanted to give those
users a fully managed
non-relational schemaless
datastore to
truly grow their apps.
MIKE MILLER: Boy, there
are a lot of ways I
want to answer this.
Number one maybe being that it's
not Amazon, which is kind
of nice as a change.
The reality is we built a
database as a service.
And we've got to bring that
to the place where
the developers are.
There's a large and rapidly
growing number of
developers on Google.
So for us, there are all kinds
of technical reasons about why
it's a great platform.
If you're building a CDN,
you want to know the
network very well.
And reliable latencies
are huge as well--
so private backbone.
But really, the number one thing
for us is footprint,
like I need to get as close
to the edge as possible.
And so Google has one of the
biggest, if not the biggest
deployments globally.
So for us, that's massive.
TYLER HANNAN: So Will mentioned
this, and I'm going
to repeat it.
The private backbone between
datacenters matters.
Data locality is an important
concern when you're
distributing a global
database.
But also, when scalability is a
problem, it's a problem now.
And it's a business
problem now.
And so the ability to simply
scale by using the tools that
are provided to developers
regardless of which database
solution you choose is an
important and, I think, unique
component of Compute Engine and
something that if I could
surmise, will be a
continued area of
improvement in the future.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So it looks
like we have some questions.
AUDIENCE: My name's Drew
[? Broadly. ?]
I'm from New Zealand.
One of the questions I have--
because the people from
Cassandra aren't up here, and
I thought I'd take
the opportunity--
and what are your opinions on
distributed counters, and
what's your approach?
TYLER HANNAN: So distributed
counters was the question.
Sorry, I'm repeating that,
because I'm hard of hearing.
We've been working hard on, in
concert with INRIA Research in
France, on CRDTs and looking at
building counters that can
survive in eventually
consistent world.
We've also been working on
adding some strong consistency
capabilities into Riak.
I think they're there.
I think they're coming soon.
I think they're a lot
of scary math.
So it'll be interesting to see
how the market adopts.
But I think we're on the
cusp of distributed
counters being a reality.
MIKE MILLER: Yeah, CRDTs are
definitely a hot area of
implementation.
I don't know about how hot there
are research-wise, but
we're certainly seeing users who
have implemented a large
number of those things
in reality.
But overall, I think a little
bit of a shift in mindset when
you're writing something.
A lot of people who come to
NoSQL will get there after
going to the fully denormalized
state.
So you start with start schemas,
and you work up all
the way to full.
You normalize.
And that mindset is something
that we have to help show
people the best ways
to solve problems.
I think one of the things that
we also see that's available
now in the majority of these
systems is going to an
immutable data model where if
you're modeling a state
machine, every transition
is modified--
modeled as, say, a new document
in our system, a new
JSON document.
And the aggregate state
is summed up
in a secondary index.
So that's a really powerful
way already without even
appealing to something as
complicated as CRDTs to deal
with rapidly changing things
that have to be summed.
So concrete examples--
leader boards, amounts of money
in accounts, virtual
currencies, which maps a very
real large amount of dollars.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: I think they
summed it up well.
AUDIENCE: Are you two able to
give an input on it or not?
WILL SHULMAN: I'll be honest
with you, I've given almost no
thought to distributed
counters.
So sorry about that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: More time
for more questions.
AUDIENCE: So many of my
friends who initially
recommended MongoDB to me,
later, I noticed they grew
disillusioned with
document-oriented databases.
I'm wondering how have you
noticed organizations dealing
with the engineering scaling
issues of actually engineering
applications with
document-oriented databases versus--
I'm not talking about the whole
technical scaling, but
building their applications.
WILL SHULMAN: So for
document-oriented databases is
specifically your question?
AUDIENCE: Right.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Sounds like
a great question for Will.
WILL SHULMAN: I think if you're
not just talking about
the technical aspects, which
obviously involve sharding and
using the horizontal scalability
aspects of
MongoDB, from an organizational
standpoint, we
find the customers are just
loving MongoDB even actually
if it's not a large
data problem.
So the ability to not-- and like
I mentioned in my talk,
almost every programming
language now is an
object-oriented programming
language.
So having a rich object data
structure in your database is
really just unbelievable for
developer productivity.
If you're using something like
server side JavaScript or
Python or Ruby, and you have
this object in memory, you
could just throw it into
the Datastore.
We're finding that people are
really finding the schemaless
nature of Mongo, the ability
that you could just add
fields, the ability to just
insert things and take them
out without having to do a lot
of transformations, is really
helping from an organizational
standpoint, which is what I
think you were getting at,
really scale development,
really scale productivity.
MIKE MILLER: Sorry, I didn't
mean to steal the mic.
I think it's a good question
if I interpret it
a little bit myself.
I think one of the questions
is something
like a document database.
You're [? trading ?]
JSON on the wire over HTTP.
There's a lot of ways
to model your data.
And that flexibility, again,
like education in terms of
what is the best way for a
particular system to solve
this problem.
In our system, there are at
least four different ways to
store one to many, many,
many relationships.
And so a lot of that has to do
with just getting out best
practices and understanding,
oh, my problem
falls in this bucket.
And that's something that I
think the communities in
general are rapidly starting to
try to get down on paper.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: I'll
add to it.
To touch on the point of
everybody that's doing mobile
as well today, I think there's
other things you want to
consider as well in terms of
going after that approach and
going after doing
document stores.
While they're schemaless and
they're great and it makes it
very easy to scale, you do lack
the things that you get
from, say, doing row-column,
where you want to do, I want a
subset of my property, because
you're trying to minimize the
payload that's going back over
the wire to your mobile
clients, especially when you're
doing a back end as a
service type of solution when
there's no server side code to
filter out.
You're literally going from
the mobile device-- iOS,
Android-- back to
the Datastore.
You're like, no, no, no, I don't
need 100 properties.
I only need the first five,
because that's actually what
I'm showing in my limited
real estate view there.
TYLER HANNAN: And I think this
is an important question, so
I'm actually going to answer it
slightly differently, which
is in the world of relational
databases, we started modeling
our data by saying what
answers do I have.
In the world of NoSQL,
non-relational databases, we
start modeling our data
by saying what
questions do I have.
So you could think of it as a
top down approach rather than
a bottom up.
And it's not an either/or.
There are situations where
you may want a relational
datastore alongside a
non-relational with something
specific for geospatial
indexing.
That polyglot deployment is
important, and it's something
that, as developers, I think we
can be excited about that
we're not limited to
a set of tools.
We have a broad range of tools
to draw from based upon
application need.
It's not a one to one
application to
database model anymore.
It's a one to many, depending on
what's living inside of the
application.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
Spanner.
Could you speak about how it
differs from BigTable, and are
there any plans to expose
it via an API?
CHRIS RAMSDALE: To repeat the
question, I think question
was, I had mentioned Spanner,
and was there--
AUDIENCE: How does it differ
from BigTable, and are there
any plans to expose
it via an API?
CHRIS RAMSDALE: So it doesn't
differ BigTable.
It differs from Megastore and
how they're doing the
replication.
Spanner is, in many ways, the
next evolution of Megastore in
the fact that it does
georeplication in a more
efficient manner and actually
can do time stamping across
multiple geos.
So it really gets us to where
we're trying to go, is the
global footprint.
Whereas replication between
datacenters right now via
Fiber is actually pretty good.
Think about where do you want to
be in five years from now,
10 years from now, where you're
like, I don't want to
actually think about, unless
it's for compliancy reasons,
where my data is.
I just have a bunch of users.
I have a great service
that's taking off.
I'm the next Tumblr, Pinterest
or whatever.
And they are all
over the place.
And my data needs to
be replicated.
So then I go across the Pacific
or I go across all the
dark fiber that's in the
Atlantic or whatnot, it just
happens in microseconds.
So that's really the
goal of Spanner.
And that's why I was looping it
back to Megastore, because
Megastore is the service that
actually does the replication
for us and for Google.
There's a question about APIs.
And yes, there's many
conversations underway about
should we surface an API
on top of Spanner.
I have my personal beliefs that
I think that what we're
doing inside of HRD, inside of
the Cloud Datastore is the
right way to go, because we're
actually pulling in--
if you flip the bit on all of
Google's infrastructure right
now and made it public, I think
everybody would freak out.
It's not the way I think that
everybody wants to program.
So what I like what we're doing
inside of the cloud
platform is we're putting that
layer on top of it that makes
it really palatable for
developers to come along and
use some pretty mind-blowing
infrastructure.
AUDIENCE: So is that a no?
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Say what?
AUDIENCE: Is that a no?
CHRIS RAMSDALE: No, no,
no, that's a not yet.
It might.
It's actually been debated
inside of Google right now.
AUDIENCE: Hi, [? Stephan ?]
[INAUDIBLE] from Rovio
Entertainment in Finland.
I was wondering if you have some
advice, ideas, or tools
to deal with backup and restore
strategy in reasonable
time, because usually you deal
with huge amounts of data and
distributed databases.
And while most of them address
disaster scenarios already in
this redundancy setup, there's
still a possibility that
you'll cause data corruption by
bugs in the application--
not that that would
ever happen.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Yeah, in
actuality, it's the
application bugs that get you
all the time, not that Rovio
would write any bugs.
Like the pigs wouldn't go off
into space somewhere else and
attack a planet.
We have a backup and restore
functionality right now that's
in its very much alpha
phase, I would say.
That's user-initiated.
We're in the process of
moving that into a
fully managed service.
It goes with the whole theme
of what we're trying to do.
And that just gets us to
where we want to be.
That's the baseline
functionality.
That's an epic backup
is what I call it.
So if you have 10 terabytes a
day, you're doing that backup
all the time.
And one could do the math in
their head and say, that's not
necessarily the way I want
to be doing things.
So then what we're going to do
is take it from there and go
into doing incremental backups
with snapshots as well.
So what you get is,
you get full
backups that are reliable.
Then you get backups for
cheap-- incremental.
And then you get backups with
snapshotting, which gives you
the consistency that you
can do them at anytime.
WILL SHULMAN: So we run a cloud
service around MongoDB.
There's lots of interesting
techniques that you can use
with Mongo to deal with
this problem.
And you're right.
Almost always we deal with node
failure via replication.
But human error is always when
people come calling us and
say, hey, can you restore
backup for us?
So we have a backup system that
does snapshotting and
does the typical type of backup
you might expect.
But there's other technologies,
both core to
MongoDB and stuff that we're
building that's going to help
even further.
So one is a MongoDB technology
called Delayed Slaves, or
Delayed Replication.
So you can actually set up a
node that lags behind the
master by an hour,
a day, a week.
And that's one technique some
customers used to say OK, I
fat fingered the database.
I'm going to go to this Delayed
Slave that's maybe an
hour behind.
And I'll have a set of data that
is not corrupted by the
bug or whatever caused
the problem.
The other nice thing about
MongoDB is it has an op log of
every operation.
This is what replication
is driven off of.
So you can actually restore
to a snapshot.
Let's say you restore to a
snapshot from a day ago.
Then you could replay the op log
to bring the data state to
the operation right before the
operation that started to make
things go wrong or started
to corrupt the database.
So you could actually
do point in time.
And that's also something
we're looking to
productize as well.
MIKE MILLER: Maybe I'll
just add an anecdote.
I'm sure everybody here has
backup solutions and a story
there available on
the product page.
One interesting piece of data,
though-- and this is not fully
quantitative.
I'm just trying to this
in my mind right now.
But I would estimate about 80%
of the user-initiated errors
we've had are simply database
deletes by mistake.
You have a REST API that
looks really clean.
And it's like, you've
got a verb.
You've got a base URL.
You've got a collection
or a database.
And then you've got a document,
maybe other things
behind that.
And you have a script
that somehow has an
empty string in there.
You just dropped the whole
database by mistake.
And so actually about 80% of the
things that we have to do
for users are restoring
databases
that they just deleted.
And so number one thing you
can do is rename files in
garbage collects.
There are basic operational
policies you can take that
allow to, like, oh, that
email came in.
Yeah, we just restored
it right away.
Flip the bit.
So it's interesting
to see actually.
One of the things we should do
is talk about as you run the
service, what are the things you
learn about the users that
really drive how you go
back and feed that
back into the product?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Don't make
delete calls too easy.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Just
do what we do.
We make the writes, the delete
actually really expensive.
And the storage is really cheap,
so you just keep the
data around.
I've got to poke
fun at myself.
TYLER HANNAN: A whole
slew of options and
opportunities with Riak.
I'll just reiterate what the
gentleman said, which is
backups are, again, a business
challenge in addition to a
technology challenge,
particularly when you're
considering latency.
So whether you adopt a backup
strategy that's a fully
replicated cluster that mirrors
production or whether
you use some cool syincing
technology or whether you do
more of a traditional sort of
replication, whatever you
choose, plan for failure.
That's my key message about
distributed systems.
Plan for failure.
And test it.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So we have a
little under six minutes left
for questions.
AUDIENCE: So my question is
very much related to the
previous one.
In human error events, if you
have an append-only database,
where instead of deleting or
updating, then you can stop
those errors as well.
Do you guys have any plans to
support an append-only style
database as a first class
kind of product?
MIKE MILLER: I can tell you.
Sorry, sometimes it sounds
like it cuts out.
So we use modified portions
of the Apache
CouchDB storage engine.
So it's an append-only
copy and write b-tree
So we're never overriding
our data.
We compact it away in the
background after so much time
or so many revisions.
But we haven't fully leveraged
that yet to productize very
clever incremental slash point
in time backup service.
So there are great things you
can do that, depending on the
storage model you choose for
primary and secondary indexes.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: So HRD and the
Cloud Datastores, since we're
built on top of BigTable,
we're already doing the
append-only.
This is why it's actually much
easier just to leave your data
around, rather than it is to go
and do writes to delete it.
And then to dovetail back into
what I was talking about to
the guy from Rovio is that,
given that we have the
foundation laid to allow us to
do incremental and snapshot
backups at time based on the way
we're doing the appending.
AUDIENCE: So there's a lot of
cool technologies being
introduced and rolled
out to developers.
But with the database, I always
wonder why are we still
using HTTP to interface
with the data?
Why are we using a stateless
connection?
And my personal challenge is
using high concurrency at
Python, you start accumulating
large file descriptors for all
of the HTTP connections that
have come and gone and not
been collected in time.
And so it's a real challenge
managing that versus when I'm
using Postgres or something
with traditional binary
stateful connection,
I don't seem to
run into those problems.
So is there a plan to maybe
standardize a binary protocol
or a stateful protocol
for these types of
services coming out?
WILL SHULMAN: So MongoDB
actually has
a binary wire protocol.
It actually isn't an
HTTP interface.
MongoLab actually does offer
an HTTP interface on top of
the Mongo protocol, and you can
use it if you'd like to.
But I'd say 90% of our customers
use one of the
standard MongoDB drivers
supported by 10 Gen.
So almost every programming
language you might want to
talk to MongoDB from, there's
a driver, and it's a tight
wire protocol.
It's based on the BSON spec,
which is at bsonspec.org.
And yes, so very well
understood.
And all the drivers have
connection pooling and things
like that from a traditional
relational database, what
you're probably used to.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: But
I'll add to that.
I think that the way we think
about is, with the stateful
connections, whether you're
doing socket or whatnot, it
ends up being a bottleneck in
your system when you're trying
to scale out horizontally.
So that's one.
And so we try to avoid those
wherever we can.
So HTTP just happens to
be the mechanism.
Maybe that's going to
change over time.
Hopefully it does.
There's a fair amount of
overhead to bring those
connections up.
And then two, what I'll add is,
think about it in terms of
when the server goes away, when
it really is just a bunch
of mobile clients, when they're
actually doing, when
we've got all the auth figured
out and things like that.
So you're making a connection
back from the client.
The last thing you'd want
to have is a persistent
connection over extremely
flaky carrier
connection like 3G or 4G.
So I think we've got to start
thinking in terms of the
paradigm shift has already
happened to going to stateless.
MIKE MILLER: Yeah, I'll
completely second that.
We actually only support HTTP
connection because we're firm
believers--
well, if we look at our user
base, it's over half
JavaScript.
A lot of that is directly
from the clients.
And so we think a decade from
now, a, nobody will run their
own databases.
And b, we'll be, if not
completely in a two-tier
stack, then something that looks
like a very, very thin
middle tier, which is
just for session
management and sign-ups.
And it's going to be
direct connection
from your mobile device.
So for that, now HTTP, maybe
in the future, web sockets,
things that are a little
bit faster and
lighter weight protocols.
But I think that's
the direction the
world's moving in.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
Next question?
AUDIENCE: Do you have any advice
if the data is actually
graph-like, where it doesn't
fit into a document.
For example, the data is big
but you need to traverse.
Think about Knowledge Graph,
but the data is huge.
How do you distribute it?
Any advice?
TYLER HANNAN: So the question
was, advice regarding modeling
graph style data.
I'm going to say something
that maybe people at my
company wouldn't like, which
is you should look into a
graph database.
They're there.
They're really freaking amazing,
and they do their job
really well.
So if that's the model that you
need, I would encourage
you to look into the people
who are building a data
storage for that model.
MIKE MILLER: I'll answer that.
If your data fits in memory,
Neo4j is your database, that's
pretty spectacular.
It's got a REST API.
It's awesome.
And it's an incredible team
with a great community.
If it doesn't fit there, certain
type of graph problems
are amenable to MapReduce
processing, not all.
There's some great talks from
Twitter about how they're
swinging their Hadoop hammer,
because it's the only hammer
they have, but how they get into
some really funny spots,
where they have to get very
clever with approximate sets
and hash tables and
things like that.
But some problems are
well-suited to MapReduce.
So that opens up a lot
of doors for you.
It's about data modeling,
again.
But if that doesn't work for
you, you're probably not going
to solve the distributed
graph problem yourself.
The community has been working
on that for a very long time.
So we should probably start to
lean on these guys over here
about maybe open sourcing
something around Pregel.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Noted.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So we're
just about out of time.
I would encourage you to
come up and talk to
us after the session.
We'll probably move a little
bit outside, so we can
actually let the next
folks set up.
But I just wanted to
say thank you.
Thank you to all of you.
Thank you to our panelists for
coming out here today.
[APPLAUSE]